yeah i guess like coming to japan i am
impressed by
the [ __ ] variety of sex toys
i mean i i i see it way more often
because you know i'm [ __ ] dating
sydney and it's her [ __ ] job to
review these different types of things
but man they they are so imaginative
and i'm i i unironically like love
going to just [ __ ] like there's one in
akihabara that i always go to called
love mercy
i think it's called it's like under the
bridge and it's like a four-story
[ __ ] sex shop
oh yeah and that's right in the middle
of akihabara right now
it doesn't look like a adult store yeah
and like the fourth floor like the top
floor is like no females allowed because
like that's where all of like the guy
toys and like the
the [ __ ] up porn is and i was like how
bad could it be so i went up there i was
like
yeah i mean i'm allowed on this floor
technically under the rules of the store
but i i don't know
i don't want to be on this floor it
feels illegal just being
there man things when you gather when
you go i feel like i'm committing a
felony yeah when you get up higher and
then you see the sex dolls the actual
like
oh yeah and they're [ __ ] expensive
too there's like 10 grand right yeah
yeah
like the good quality ones i'm like
what's the difference i don't know
like the thought of having to clean out
like a fake person what is the main
show what's disgusting what is the
maintenance cost on these [ __ ] dolls
man
like they they must be more expensive to
[ __ ] maintain than just
going out to a soap land but that's what
i mean that's what i'm thinking it's
like these things are so expensive
you're better off going to like a soap
land you know ten times this is the
shame right
right i i get it it's a bit different
but i get it i get it though like the
financially it makes sense
yeah it's a shame the shame of having to
go to a prostitute or something
basically
i think i'd rather do that than [ __ ]
why a dog the shame of having someone
look back at you
as opposed to like looking at lifeless
eyes that they can't
judge hey if other people want to
[ __ ] do it that's fine i don't care
yeah i can't do that man yeah the shame
would be too much for me
i had a mate who like couldn't go to any
strip clubs because he was just like
yeah going to a strip club it's just
like looking at porn that could look
back at you man
i've never been to a strip club and they
always just seem weird like i i just the
idea of it
and it's sad because everyone always
tells me the food is like normally the
best part of it and
what i would not order food in the
street
the boys go to a strip club just to have
like a five course delicate meal
man why not i would it's like
it's like your friend is like yo i know
you're [ __ ] great strip club
stakes are [ __ ] boring someone said
like i can't remember who it was in
america they're like yeah dude the wings
were bombed
does that mean you've just gone to too
many strip clubs where you go you go
there and there's just like naked girls
dancing you're like no no no no give me
the wings
i would pay for a youtube series where
someone is like very
loudly in like a music blaring he's like
reviewing a strip club
and the wings i would pay good money for
that it's my review bro
yeah like a report of the week in a
strip club like reviewing the wings
he's like can you turn the music down a
little bit
slate please out of the way i i fear for
what i don't know
i don't want to use any of these sex
toys because i don't i don't want to
start liking them yeah
because i feel like i'm just going to
get more and more extravagant with it
until the maintenance costs are through
the roof all right i'm happy with where
i'm at right now
just just beating my meat just getting
it done my own trusty hand you know
it does the job i don't need more than
that that's that's why i'm afraid of
likes trying something like vr porn you
know what i mean where it's just like
this this is going what if i like it
this is going an extra mile here this is
this
this like what yeah exactly like what if
i like it what if i experience something
new from this i don't know i don't want
i don't want to i'm not i'm in a happy
way
she recently bought a vr headset but i
bought it to play [ __ ] games okay
i want to play the last life index there
is no way there is a part of you that is
like
i gotta try this out there is no way
there isn't a part of it of course there
is but like
so i just don't like the idea of coming
with a headset on
there's something about that that feels
wrong like i'm wearing a big ass headset
with these controllers and [ __ ] like
i don't want to [ __ ] you kidding me
you kidding i can imagine like
i can imagine just like like you climax
and like the post not shame must be on
another level right
because she's just a headshot
you've got the controllers you're like
oh this is this is where my life is
beat saber okay i just
yeah again like i i feel like i don't
know you just did a video on this didn't
you where you went to illusion
yeah yeah i went to illusion and played
the vr porn games that they made
it's [ __ ] weird like i don't know i i
did like a
safe for work one because barely safe if
you were in the privacy of your home
could you not do it
if i tried really hard maybe what do you
mean if you could try really hard like
if i was if i was given like 30 minutes
to myself like maybe
i'm sure i could manage to come to
anything if i had 30 minutes that's what
i'm saying
it's like it's it's not the optimal
thing i would use because it's like i
don't know
this it's like there's a part it was
really fun to do yeah because it's just
so ridiculous
but there's just so much about it that's
just so jank where you just like
oh okay i'm supposed to be lying down in
this thing but i'm
also standing up and if i look down i
just look into the guy's neck
i mean it's just a bit weird that's the
thing about vr porn right i mean you
have to be
dedicated to this wank session you know
what i mean there are so many steps you
are putting on
just to jack off you know what if what
if the like the sensors get like
they're like stop working midway mid
wank
finish finish just yeah i guess so i
guess so
it's it's it's not exactly a casual wank
is it you know
[Music]
like